three attacks on three different
hospitals today including we were just
talking about an attack that hit near
the Indonesian hospital that's in the
north of the Gaza Strip uh one that the
health Ministry spokesperson was
detailing a little earlier on about a
medical Convoy leaving the largest
hospital in Gaza that's al-shifa uh that
was apparently clearly identified uh
including the time at which it would
leave to bring critically wounded
patients from alifa to be treated abroad
out of the Gaza Strip and that uh was uh
that Convoy was struck with an Untold
number of people killed uh as we speak
I'm as we look at those developments I'm
reminded of what the US Secretary of
State said a few hours ago which is that
Israel has a right to defend itself but
the way how it does so matters those
were his words how it does so matters
and blinkin says that he's trying to
impress upon the Israelis that they have
to minimize civilian casualties it on
the same day that he's there saying that
they've attacked at least three
hospitals I mean it doesn't seem that
they're listening to him well let's
agree first of all that with these three
developments happening today this leaves
no U ambiguity and no questions that
these escalations on Israel sides are
deliberate uh we saw the bus laying on
the ground on a Rashid streets just
people walking in the streets right so
it's not like a a mil a Hamas leader is
H in in a compound or something it's
people walking in the streets and
buddies are laying all over the Rashid
Street and the medical Convoy as well
and this is by the way this is the
bodies of people who were trying to
listen to what the Israelis were telling
them go from the north go to the South
and they're taking one of those two main
roads that that can bring them to the
South exactly and on top of that the
Indonesian hospital that has been under
attack for the past week so far so with
these three developments this leaves us
with no option but to believe that this
is Del
and linking this to blink's pressure
this could be actually to read these
developments or this deliberate
escalation is a message to blinkin that
Israel is not listening and Israel will
continue to do what it what it wants to
do without any uh care about what the US
is saying what blink saying or what the
Biden Administration is saying so this
is because this is happening the same
day this is happening just right after
the blink is uh given his message to to
the Israelis and probably also the uh
private pressure that's being exerted on
isra from the US Administration so
Israel is on a rampage Israel is
deliberately escalating uh targeting
every human being in Gaza and this is
going to put the US Administration in a
much much more difficult position to try
to support or to justify U the
escalations and what Israel is doing in
in Gaza and this requires the US
Administration is to take a position now
before tomorrow because obviously Israel
is not listening and Israel's doing you
know what they want to do it's driven by
retaliation it's driven by destruction
of Gaza is driven by uh total uh
demolishing of everything in in Gaza
houses and targeting people and all of
that level and anyone who U from the
policy makers especially Western policy
makers who who tolerates this kind of
behavior is complicit and is not is not
only comp but it's partner in this
because because with all these clear
messages you cannot hide behind these
vague statements about abiding by
international law or by uh what Biden
was saying is securing a private a
special uh a safe passage for food and
for medicine those the people in Gaza
need this mad n Israeli Madness of
bombing to stop they don't need to to to
eat to F to give them food they need
this first of all is to stop and the US
Administration cannot continue to be in
this conflicting position with this uh
with this Paradox of trying to providing
the the uh providing Israel with the
American made bombs to bomb Gaza and at
the same time give them food you cannot
give a bomb and a food at the same time
you going to stop the bomb first of all
before you talk about the you know
that's really interesting because
there's been this Paradox at the center
of of how the US and Israel are handling
this whole Gaza situation which was
bombit but under us pressure and advice
also allowing some of the food that's
something we definitely need to we'll
keep that for a little later that
because it's something we need to um to
discuss Ibrahim thank you very much
thank
you now we were talking about the US
Secretary of State Anthony blinkin
because he arrived in Israel on Friday
on a diplomatic T he says that he's
spoken to Israeli leaders about taking
concrete steps remember what we were
just saying concrete steps to minimize
the Palestinian civilian death toll so
he met with prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu and with President Isaac
Herzog in Tel
Aviv we provided Israel advice that only
the best of friends can offer on how to
minimize civilian deaths while still
achieving its objectives of fighting and
finishing Hamas terrorists and their
infrastructure of
violence today I spoke with prime
minister Netanyahu and other senior
officials about concrete steps to do
that President Biden has consistently
stressed the need for Israel to operate
according to International humanitarian
law I also emphasize that the protection
of civilians must take place not just in
Gaza but also in the West Bank where
incitement and extremist violence
against Palestinians must be stopped and
perpetrators held
accountable third we need to
substantially and immediately increase
the sustained flow of humanitarian
assistance into Gaza and getting
American citizens and other foreign
Nationals out of Gaza we believe that
each of these efforts would be
facilitated by humanitarian pauses by
Arrangements on the ground that increase
security for civilians and permit the
more effective and sustained delivery of
humanitarian
assistance Alan fiser is in occupied
East Jerusalem Allan this was blinken's
thirdd visit to Israel since the start
of this conflict uh where day 28 of the
conflict look I was taking notes
throughout the whole speech and there
were a lot of big picture ideas not many
details uh among the big picture ideas
full support for Israel but minimize the
Palestinian Civ uh Palestinian Civ
civilian beg your pardon civilian
casualties increase the aid to Gaza and
work towards a two-state solution you
also address who might be in Gaza if and
when this conflict ends he saying it's
GNA have to be not Hamas not Israel but
we don't know who else it might be so
again the the point I was hoping that
you could kind of elaborate on is big
picture ideas but publicly at least not
a whole lot of
details he's not coloring in between the
lines is he he he's struggling to
articulate exactly what the concrete
measures would be the idea that he was
really pushing was this suggestion of
humanitary imposes to allow Aid in and
to allow some captives and foreign
Nationals in the injured out and what
the Israelis have said from Benjamin
netanyahu's own words immediately after
is we continue to go full force now the
idea of humanitarian poses Anthony blink
linked to the idea of captives being
freed he said but how when and what
where we do that still has to be worked
out so it seems that he may have an idea
but the Israelis have their own idea of
how this war is to be prosecuted and no
matter what the United States says
they're going to push ahead the problem
that Anthony blinkin has he's aware of
growing criticism internationally
believing that the United States could
do more to Reign Israel in and he's also
aware of the growing criticism back in
the United States that Joe Biden should
be more forceful with Israel and try and
reduce the number of casualties and the
number of dead which is growing every
hour okay so what more can you tell us
or explain about how Israel is receiving
this specifically Israel prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu because I mean he he
does say that he appreciates the support
the many levels of us support but also
seems not to heed much of their
advice someone has described it on
social media as the person who gets the
aid saying we're not going to listen to
you and there may be an element of that
what Benjamin Netanyahu has said is very
clear no humanitarian poses until this
start releasing captives we are going to
continue Prosecuting the war at full
force which suggests that if there are
civilian casualties it's not something
that Israel is they would argue not
deliberately seeking but they're not
going to take extra steps to minimize
what they're doing and so all of the
things that Anthony blinkin wanted to
get from the Israelis he has essentially
failed and he's heading now to a man
where he's going to speak to Arab
leaders including King Abdullah and they
will be putting pressure on him to try
and stop the war it's what the Jordanian
foreign minister said several hours ago
that his message to Anthony blinkin will
be get them to stop the war and so he is
faced with a very difficult situation of
trying to support Israel as much as
possible but realizing that a lot of the
things he wants to see come about lie
entirely in the gift of the Israeli
government and at the moment they have a
plan for the war and they're not
changing it for
anyone alzer's Alan fiser reporting
there on the visit of US Secretary of
State Anthony blinkin to Israel today
thank you very much
Alan a missile has hit the entrance of
the alifa hospital killing at least 15
Palestinians with many others injured
and a second Israeli strike then
targeted a convoy of ambulances carrying
the wounded from alifa hospital towards
the Rafa Crossing mattz Gilbert is a
Doctor Who's worked in Gaza and he's in
close contact with colleagues there he
joins us uh from Cairo first of all what
can you share with us about what your
colleagues in Gaza are telling you at
the
moment they're telling me that the
attack happened at :05 gasa time it was
a a convoy of ambulances going to
evacuate War wounded from shifa down
south to Rafa they have tried to
coordinate with icrc but the icrc
uh escort had not come so this Convoy
left shifa hospital when they were
attacked at three different points at
the gate where the videos we have seen
are from and then 200 M from the gate at
alabas Street and then further 500
meters from the gate in the ansar
roundabout I know this places well uh so
there were three different attacks on
the Convoy and as you said 15 killed we
don't know the number of wounded nor do
we precisely know the number of killed
and this
happens after the Israeli Army has been
threatening the hospitals for two weeks
to start to empty the hospitals and when
they do it they are being bonded on
their way out to another safe safe place
so this is another
horrendous type of crime as as a as a
doctor and as somebody who has worked in
Gaza and if I'm not mistaken correct me
if I'm mistaken but I believe this is
accurate you worked in Gaza during one
of the Gaza Israel Wars um given all of
that and and and that experience can you
speak to our viewers about this notion
of leaving a hospital right we're
talking about medical facilities in
which there are thousands of patients uh
from babies and incubators to possibly
cancer patients Intensive Care Unit
patients uh and obviously the many many
many patients who have come in as a
result of the injuries through the
bombardments can you speak to this
notion of emptying a hospital which is
what Israel has been telling the
hospitals in the northern Gaza Strip to
do yeah you're right I have worked in uh
shifa Hospital during the Israeli
attacks in
2006 2009 20
2002 and 2014 so I can say I have quite
an experience and I've been in convoys
going from shifa down to Rafa to go to
Egypt with wounded and I have
experienced that despite being
coordinated with International Red Cross
and having escort cars in front and back
we were shot at and we had to return so
it's a very scary experience to have the
responsibility of a patient maybe
intubated maybe on ventilator severely
wounded and you go there and you feel
quite naked and you hope that you you
really hope that International decency
and regulations will protect you not so
in Gaza not so with Palestinian
ambulances what we see today we've seen
many times The Who and un have
documented more than a 100 attacks on
Health Care Facilities during the last
three weeks this is the last in a long
line of extremely extremely cynical and
brutal attacks by these Army on patients
on health personnel on ambulances and on
hospital and I have to say if it is true
as I have reported on now from what I
heard from Gaza that there were three
distinct attacks it must have been a
targeted attack on the ambulances so why
should the Palestinians ever trust it
when the Israelis are saying leave the
hospitals you can be safe in the South
this is horrible and we so far have
reported 15 killed and you can multiply
that with three and then you have the
number of wounded but I'm I fear that
the numbers of killed will rise and
these are people who are wounded they
can't walk they're in an ambulance come
on Mr Biden Mr Biden Mr blinkin this is
your responsibility you patted the back
of Israelis for 3 weeks and said go on
go on and I hope Mr blinkin now is
stopping with this lit service of oh we
care for the for the civilians this must
be the final STW that breaks the camels
back enough is enough now Mr blink Mr
yeah Ma I don't know if this is
something that came up in your
conversations with your colleagues who
are presently in Gaza but is there uh to
your knowledge is there a way for them
is there a line of communication with
the Israelis to say we're moving a
convoy out of the hospital uh we are
doing what you want we are getting our
injured out of the area don't bomb us
when you see a convoy of cars leaving
the hospital at this hour when it looks
roughly like this
Etc absolutely you're absolutely right
there are quite sophisticated
communication channels not only here uh
in this uh occupation but in any uh
armed uh confrontational War there are
actually very delicate communication
traditions and rules you can inform via
the icrc to the enemy that we will have
um a medical transport from the there to
there at that given time the other part
that can then either say yes we hear you
or they can say confirmative we will not
attacking so so what do you infer from
that then because it would be based on
what you're telling me reasonable to
believe that the alifa staff used that
line of communication to say and in fact
the uh the um Gaza Health Ministry
spokesperson pretty much confirmed that
saying the Convoy was leaving at a
determined time
they would use that line of
communication I would assume to say
we're leaving at that time don't hit us
right absolutely and and from the
information I got right now from doctors
in the field they said that there was a
communication with the r icrc the
International Red Cross and there was an
information going to the other side
about this Convoy if that proves true we
have a we have a gruesome example that
these ambulances were trapped they were
ambushed by the Israeli Army in a
coordinated attack hitting three
different points of the ambulance
Convoy which should have been protected
and let go to the South with full
International
protection I I I I don't see any end to
the violations of the Geneva Convention
that is taking place in Gaza now I see
no end to the brutality of these attacks
and don't forget that in shifa there is
currently
50,000 internally displaced civilians
and when you see the videos from the
Gate of shifa you see how many civilians
are I mean not patient civilians are
being wounded and run around I see some
of my medical students trying to help it
is horrible but your your question is
very precise if this was coordinated the
Israelis would know that the time and
the size of the
Convoy yeah uh matad Gilbert thank you
very much for for that explanation and
for that perspective I think it's
invaluable uh and I want to just recap
that it's 1630 GMT so it's uh uh 6:30 pm
local time and mza I'll let you go thank
you so much for your time today by the
way we really appreciate you coming on
the show to explain that um thank you
sir sure and I'm going to bring in
Ibrahim fap because this is something we
need to talk about as well um your
associate professor of conflict
resolution um so mads was telling
us and I think not all of our viewers
will know this there is a way and it's
pretty easy because it's established
that we're in this fifth Israel Gaza War
there is a line of communication between
uh places like hospitals and the
Israelis and the hospitals essentially
can pick up the phone and say we're
leaving with the injured we're leaving
with civilians this is not a military
Target we're leaving at this place we're
leaving at this time do not hit us so
you would assume that that message was
put out to the uh Israelis we're not
reporting this as fact but mads was
explaining that's how it usually works
um and yet in the case of the alifa
hospital we're seeing a convoy of
civilians of people who are critically
injured be targeted it seems
deliberately targeted uh just as they
were leaving a hospital what do we what
do we make of that well on the day the
blinkin is saying we're giving advice
the quote is we provideed advice to the
Israelis on how to minimize civilian
deaths I do not thank you for this but I
do not think that the issue is
logistical is how to communicate or how
to uh like for example we can build a
hotline we can where you can you know
deliver messages and uh uh you know
coordinate these things but the issue is
not Lo it's not logistical the issue is
political the issue is uh the vision of
Israel how it's conducting this war and
how it's managing this war it seems to
me it seems to me that there is a much
bigger thing uh Vision uh within
Israel uh you know the way they're
running this war which is basically the
mass expulsion of the Palestinians from
from Gaza because this is from Gaza or
from northern Gaza well it's from Gaza
to begin with which is we are we started
seeing uh more pressure on CCE to open
the borders uh the with with Sinai so
for the Palestinians to go there so um
and why that's why we are seeing these
very clear messages like bombing a
medical Convoy or people walking in the
streets to to send the message that no
one will be safe we're targeting
everyone while the political pressure on
CeCe is to open the borders with siai so
whenever they are able to secure such
kind of an agreement so everyone can
leave if I follow that logic it would be
in Israel's interest to let them leave
right if the point is to move gazin out
exact exactly well that's why but
they're not letting many leave since
those convoys that are heading south or
some of them are being attacked well
that's why what makes us believe that
the uh Israeli intention is not for them
to move South but to move outside Gaza
towards Sinai because those who are
moving to the South and are listening to
the Israeli instructions of going to the
South they're being targeted right so
that's why I mean we can't take this and
not only this not just the ones that
targeted one one when you call for
people to go to a specific area this is
an international conflict it's called a
safe zone right and safe Zone should not
be touched but Israel is did not stop
bombing the south from day one hunis and
the hospitals and every every other
areas in the South so this is not a safe
Zone this is not for people to go the
the much bigger message is for everyone
is to leave Gaza is the mass expulsion
is a newba and this is has been said and
communicated many times by many Israeli
officials is that uh is that that they
want to get rid of in the entire of Gaza
not just Hamas is that everyone is is
another Mass expulsion and especially if
we go back to the political statements
made especially the the past two days
enormous pressure on the Egyptian
leadership is to open the borders and
even Biden saying we do not support a
permanent leave of the Palestinian from
Gaza but a temporary right no nobody
does by the way the Egyptian president
says I we we don't want displacement of
population the jordanians by the way on
the other side of the country in the
West Bank have said the same thing Biden
said that you're essentially telling us
that the official message the Israeli
military is sending is go from the north
to the South but the real message